il ya beaucoup d'espoir livre d'hélène
ce jour là aussi on a parlé dans un peu
en loge vous parlé très librement de
sofiane de sa maladie des conséquences
éventuelles tragique on est devant lui
je vous dis mais ça me ces voix là pour
gérer ça alors déjà j'estime que dans la
mesure où si c'est lui qui souffre de la
situation c'est lui qui peut pas marcher
comme les autres petits c'est lui qui a
des douleurs etc
ils méritent de savoir exactement ce
qu'il a de le comprendre de savoir
pourquoi il se bat tous les jours et
quelle est sa différence avec les autres
parce que les autres malheureusement
nous lui dirons donc je veux qu'il en
soit conscient et je veux que ça le
motive ça le motive à se battre tous les
jours aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec sa
maladie donc je le redis l'ataxie
télangiectasie il a effectivement une
espérance de vie limitée
mais il est aussi consciente que il
sortira du lot et que sofiane voilà
sofiane sera avec nous longtemps pour
nous enquiquiner mais effectivement une
espérance de vie limitée à 20 ans mais
va sortir de la norme et puis on va tout
faire pour de toute façon c'est pour ça
qu'on est là c'est pourquoi qu'on y
trouve des solutions derrière donc bien
sûr ses passes ont cessé à feu en tant
que maman de toute façon le je le
soutiendrai jusqu'au bout je ferai le
maximum pour lui jusqu'au bout et tout
ce que je demande aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il soit heureux si c'est un petit
soleil
allez on va avancer avec ali lui sourit
ali ben j'ai même laissé un soleil non à
côté de ça on est une famille heureuse
j'ai trois enfants mais oh la la
voilà on n'a juste pas le même passé
tout en validant sur une note positive
au regard des jeunes à 5 ans et un jour
alors que vous jouer à cache cache
elle se plante devant vous qu'elle me
dit te caches michel et ses premiers
mots simon avant on m'a dit qu'elle
parlerait jamais et avec son grand
sourire elle me dit tu te cacher et je
suis dit coup quoi elle me fait qu'un
chemisier et que sa petite voix et je
suis dit je sais pas quoi dire
et du coup je le prends en riant je dis
je m'appelle pas michel et
dégage toi même évoqué elle éclate de
rire te caches which he et je lui ai dit
ça veut dire va te cacher c'est ça voilà
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré la
voix de machines et rigolade
c'est un peu un espoir aujourd'hui
comment on peut faire pour vous aider
virginie ça se tape ans alors tout
simplement lesieu au maximum sur sa page
instagram parce que c'est là c'est là
que fait les story c'est là que les
esprits que sa maladie c'est là où on
peut nous contacter et continue à
partager vraiment au maximum pour que
les gens attendent sa maladie nous ce
qu'on espère en retour c'est vraiment
avoir un contact médical
ça serait vraiment super et où qu'ils
soient où qu'ils soient en iran on fera
le nécessaire et à ce moment-là
peut-être que j'aurai besoin de dire on
a besoin financièrement pour partir à
tel endroit
aujourd'hui ça on va pas le lancer dès
maintenant ça pourrai pas vous aider
vous touche aujourd'hui honnêtement on a
besoin d'une piste
on n'a pas besoin d'argent on aura
besoin d'argent le jour où on aura une
piste après à côté de ça il ya un projet
quand même même projet plaisir pour
sofiane une dame qui s'appelle un stade
iba qui en fait d'ailleurs de gros
bisous qui a entendu les rêves de
sofiane et qui essaye de mettre des
petites choses en route pour il ya une
petite cagnotte qui est en ligne de sue
mais ce n'est pas voilà c'est pas notre
notre notre but aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment une trouver des solutions
médicales c'est à côté de saipa vendée
plaisir tabac on sera là on sent là